guys we need a captain our scurvy good
hey what are we welcome boys welcome
friends welcome to the sea of thieves
hey what's going on guys throw though my
name is Nick we got Jake Decker here Rob
and Mike are here and because this is a
great day you've been waiting for this
day for a long time I have been waiting
for this day for so long the sea of
thieves beta is here let's get right
into it we're gonna be oh so weak that
doesn't American flight makes sense
Nick before we dive a painting to
involve thanks to the dish can you Tod
tiny singing you uh gets a rundown on
what this game isn't how also what is
this it's the closed beta because that
sounds so we're currently in safeties by
rare they're closed beta which opened up
today I think it runs till the 29th and
so basically right now what we are is
were a crew of four pirates okay I don't
know who's slashing me over here and so
basically what we're gonna do today is
we're gonna go on a series of voyages
and we're gonna try to find some
treasure so we can get some gold so we
can get more voyages maybe some some
pretty sweet items like a hat like this
maybe right yeah so let's let's get into
it we'll explain kind of how things work
okay we're following you pancakes all
right it's a big face excuse me the
first thing you want to do and see if
thieves is go ahead and get some some
voyages so they're essentially your
quests or missions so we're gonna go
down here to this guild where's the
skills called it the gold hoarders guilt
so you're gonna meet these these guild
keepers here so one thing to point out -
right there's only one in this beta
there's that but they're supposed to be
multiple and again yeah so far we've
only seen
what tech factions faction yeah so let's
do this one so I'm gonna buy this voyage
here for 57 gold and alright perfect
the gold is that steep is that a steep
price you know it's a little pricey yeah
alright so now that we have that's the
first thing you want to do when you jump
to the failure now that you have it you
want to bring your crew up to your ship
and that's us guys that's us that's
that's your gonna now where is the ship
I think I saw it back it's over this way
hard time getting follow Jake ship well
there's our ship let's go it's wrong
here we go alright so we're headed to
our ship which is the next step and kind
of like starting your voltage mm-hmm I'm
sure this might change is the beta it
starts every time changing and what
respects you know I'm sure well there's
obviously more factions so this is just
a gold quarter so there's more the
faction is gonna make it up this dot R
you draw all your drunk drunk already
drunk already dude
yeah well it's good god Mike strong like
they say Sal hungover
well anyway pirates delight well he's
being gaga I'm gonna show everybody okay
just for the record this is not me like
going side to side the game is making me
do this I'm trying to go straight look
he's god dammit okay well as we made for
Michael's no I'm coming
continuing on it so here we go we are
now in kind of like the the ship
quarters here and so this is where you
propose your voyages so I'm gonna
propose the voyage of the statue of
Captain bones I think that's an x marks
the spot so once I once I lay that down
then your crewmates vote to go on that
voyage
all right Oh Mike you made it here and
sober soso voting like there's only
three people before and you know all
four I got four need to vote on
something but like we all can pick up
different ones like I could throw one
down two and then it may be like Oh
which one should we vote for alright so
now that you have your map you kind of
have on your controller here you're
gonna have your two bumpers on your left
bumper beam probably don't need to go
into specific stores where all your
items are your other bumper your right
bumper is West Adams you don't need to
tell them here's the specific controls
all right raise the anchor we're here
well we got to figure out where this is
if you look at map right so x marks the
spot
let's go down to the map and try to
figure out where it is so it's a weird
kind of shaped island almost like an
hourglass I'd say this is a very
interactive map I know it's an advanced
pirate tech okay hmm it's an iPad it's a
big iPad I judge what you got that's
nice what does it look like let's find
that so I mean if Gianluca nope there's
a concern so we're comparing what's on
my screen Oh - oh yes oh cool I passed
over big map so he's gonna mark that all
right circle marks and then where are we
hi we're pretty close we all stare
southeast apart so now comes all the
crew duties name so Mike's so who's
gonna help me raise the anchor I mean me
me me me I'll steer I will lower the
sail oh there's multiple sales all right
yeah so this also goes without saying
I'm sorry I'm not really helping out if
we spot another pirate ship form where's
oh we gotta have mom we're gonna we're
gonna yeah they give us carried a ship
poor Michael rifles right there that
ship off anchors up then you go over
here to lower the sails of which there
are 3-3 sails we sent me on a ferp
foreperson of a four-person
seafaring vessel
yeah sorry we're done going and then
it's a turn if you want to turn your
sails
I'll check the map all right so we're
currently going against the wind
we don't want maybe turn the sails a
little bit oh yeah we all have an option
we gotta go south west right yeah
there's nothing so nice so if you turn
it maybe the other one to the other way
if we turn the other thing a wild turn
we'll catch a little bit of the wind
full full portside is the one it is we
kind of started in a storm which guys
what's the rock watch the rocks do your
head straight for it straight for the
rocks nah we're good oh [ __ ] oh God go
back just go bring the sails up oh my
god someone get below Oh God yeah well
yeah of course because I mom I was just
trying to make a stream exciting Wow I
was we got some excitement I'm gonna
adjust a Filipino Uganda Oh smart move
you did that
yeah so I see you have three people
working there the anchor here you do the
fact but also if you want to turn more
you can raise sales isn't the winds not
pushing you as much yeah I learned that
from a winwaker hmm okay and black black
we're back on track right uh company I'm
steering towards the UH it's gonna take
me a while
all right I'll catch the wind here yeah
so by the time you turn around Mike
you'll probably just need to go east
I'm gonna go on look out or like
northeast a forecast I'm gonna look out
you're crazy
one get down from there why it's
dangerous he's doing look at what I'm
signing this don't look at me I'm the
captain Oh joke isn't funny Dave or
whatever it's called look with me I have
to kept an eye on you are know you've
always been a captain all right we're
off um I'm gonna level out soon
dogs coming Annie all right yeah we're
right really close to the storm we're
right on Wow they know it's pretty well
our ship has a bunch of beers on the
front look okay so
she's really cool actually the wheel on
the ship you can see this gold knob
means your level is going straight it'll
vibrate when your points straight but if
you're like this is actually left nice
but it doesn't vibrate so it looks like
it's just that it's pretty much right in
front of us is that it yeah I think
we're turning a little bit though too
much is it that thing right there's
direction like when it's to the right of
that oh it's the right well which
direction I turn some along let me let
me get on the map looks like it's crews
Drake oh wait let me turn left and we'll
look at up with cannon people Oh Oh
someone get ready to drop the anchor
yeah I'll get on the anchor well that's
another thing too is we should probably
all stock up on cannonballs right in
case we thought yes in case I should do
that well we'll do our best during the
stream to try to find some other pirates
to maybe get a little will sink bearings
scrap maybe idea but uh we welcome Jacob
I've been playing can't drop the anchor
Jake I would play most of the boring and
we haven't seen it we go solo on another
ship all right oh [ __ ]
um oh [ __ ] cool
I can probably cannon some people over
there I think we're it's directly behind
us hello chef I missed this you guys all
I think it's directly behind us you know
I was gonna can't it is that's over
there
Oh someone ran the anchor really quick
there are a couple people let's see
maybe we can maybe we can but get ready
to drop it as soon as I tell you to okay
we're gonna reply ourselves out of some
cannons here come in we're pretty far
can also fire yourself up a cannon you
don't need a friend to help it's more
fun when I can shoot it is more fun
alright get ready to drop it again when
I tell you to we can reach it now
you can drop it yep dropping anchor this
is good great decent distance from it
alright it's gonna turn hard someone
shoot me out of the can Oregon I'm a
little out can shoot yourself
alright are you in Nick aim me over
don't do it yet I want to get up okay
alright yeah shoot me wait no hold on
he's gonna get your shot Kenny's pretty
funny wait hey Wayne it chooses the
stream is just looking at a circle right
quality you go to Mike okay are you
ready
wait oh I got my feed we're a cool head
alright and you missed it where where is
the island is the shot way to go
okay number two I got it up we're here
gingka Island I'm in the one at the far
end lights out
alright it's all good I shouldn't
probably found you a little higher
alright your turn okay actually one you
can prize stay there yeah it's gonna be
right here stay here I'll say - alright
Jacob
I think the treasure is literally right
here so theoretically I'm not gonna do
it because it would make for a bad game
but we can't really fair enough I want
to we found it please say we're not
loyal to Nick as a captain we can nuni
and take this whole thing we're not
we're not there yet
no he's doing all right right now yeah
he's kind of being bossy but whatever
he's the captain
spreading the well you know mm-hmm team
right now why I'm so good there's
trapped in a communist society a bully
just complete that was an easy one
alright we can watch a shark you see the
shark here yeah
go get a couple of a couple sharks yeah
sure I think yeah oh okay first sharks
dead oh the first shark it's floating in
the air must be beta oh God
try to bite me okay all right you got it
hang it out the chest all right let's
swim out it's kind of far
yeah should we come closer to you we're
already kind of turning toward there
yeah actually you Rob you wanna raise a
[ __ ] sure I'm gonna take a while
sure buddy all right I'm gonna keep an
eye out here for some sharks I'm gonna
keep an eye out on them makes them I'll
just leave no I'm looking I'm turning
right where are you Jake we might the
banker mine I just beat up by the time
they get here oh yeah okay that's pretty
slow mister you're my person guys look
at the sunset help you so one of the
cool things about this too right now is
that you can also go by yourself too you
can manage it by yourself or with two
people so you don't have to have four
people yeah so like what is the top well
it's it's not as tough now because it's
just are designed for like one or two
people ships are designed for this ship
what this ship would be very tough oh I
see you right there
I don't level our you guys am I going
too fast for you guys throwing you a
Cuban yes all right press X right there
yeah I know I grabbed on I was like oh
come on man
yeah thank you strong
we got [ __ ] we got a majestic in this
yeah what a beauty
what a viewing leveled out we have to
name our ship which we named our ship
the swamp Goblin SS doesn't want goblin
SS mud Punk oh I like SS mud punk
anything oh it's gonna be a woman me SS
be a pirate name now it's gotta be a
woman's name like Gen a
really stuck on Tom Hanks movies it's
Jenny cuz I can say Jenny old everybody
on yeah we are don't you hang around all
right where we going now where's the
next map picking us that was it I think
so I'll go I'm gonna propose another
another voyage you're gonna bring that
chest back for okay no can we can focus
all our decks yeah I put it below deck
while we get some more first if we can
get a get a nice little stock pot I know
we have to no let's do one more just one
from the dude no I have one okay Cory
goes so we're gonna propose the
ill-gotten loot of mad alley
I'm sure it's a day long this is a long
Oh
how long was the one we just did I have
to so it's twice ah then we are boys -
doing it this Rumble there should be
just pumped oh wow where is this island
coming then open up this I'm moving a
small time off God oh there's Bobby
holes in the hull somebody god can
someone yeah I can hear that I can hear
it the water is seeping in yeah no one
dropped anchor oh boy we need I got one
we need we're try I'm serious yeah
you're fine you're right you have to
bail okay we're sailing something drop
the anchor oh you're feeling up more
wait how do I now I think I got it
patched okay yeah there's two I know I
got those two oh no no bail bail bail do
we get all them well we got I don't know
I'm all right Cody I'm putting the water
back
to the water yeah you have to scoop it
and then dump it at the top
see ya it works I don't know I didn't
think I'm rare would be that I thought
oh no and you can't run with it full
yeah and I ran it thump down okay that
was quick
well you can spritz it alright yeah I'm
gonna get on the wheel before we crash
on another island cuz we still did not
drop an anchor I don't think alright is
the anchor up okay we have an x mark
yeah now I just lowered it because I
thought it was no no don't oh yeah all
right
we have a riddle map so the riddle
starts the sunken Grove hides the secret
wonder a hidden stash of glinting
plunder sunken grows and probably just
part of the map I have to go to the
sunken growth once that gets tasted a
we're gonna help me with this now oh
[ __ ] I'm gonna turn this is sunk and
it's just gonna be called sunken grow
right that iron is oh my word this takes
forever by yourself wow that's quite the
island yeah with what is the chain to
clay and if you want to get there - yeah
our second map is no it's different
what's there actually am I going you
want to go to the north east oh yeah
actually north by northeast we're
steering toward this island right now
is anyone steering I'm steering but I
didn't know that I was up so I was kind
of going straight for a while we're a
drop anchor we were just saying uh-oh
check the map again bless you can
someone get on the map downstairs yeah
I'm done I'm doing I think we're good
we're good
tell me when it's straight I can
straighten out now probably yeah you'd
straight now yep look at that look at
look at look at the area where we had to
ditch the controls you know I got water
and save our ship we were turning left
the entire time yeah all right we are
heading straight for the island pretty
much just try to be a little bit closer
this time so you can like it doesn't
take as long to swim on the boat god
these are ugly pirate Mike would you
like some music yeah
play some play me some - mini Jacob here
he's got the audio in here
[Music]
just play the Valkyries yes so we get up
here and play some music okay okay we
don't have any in our map just so it's
someone got on that so dark I'll go back
down there man
there are ways in this play like you can
play I'll go than that does your does
your arise you later and I keep going
straight keep you and turn off with the
trigger you can turn your blame on it
off this is the flame door so a lot of
people I think we're one green we're one
green what the end game that I wouldn't
notice that I have no clothes on yeah
[Music]
you are weird
you look like rips that's what I am your
new tee
you're like Tommy Wiseau clothes Mughal
life a little bit Mike sorry I'm gonna
distracted right now yeah right here
I mean I'll get closer I mean someone
get up get ready to drop anchor night
yeah the anchor oh yeah let me get close
that's a big island I'll pull up next to
it can someone guide me from up with the
front of ship keep going keep going keep
going I go right though there's a fire
here and I went too far right you're
good you're gonna do good I only drop
anchor ah you could drop me - how about
happened Debs
yeah boy oh yeah drop it yeah yeah that
was pretty good
coughs game goodbye good job alright
good job Jenna Jenna Jenna can I go to
the Atlas time so to stay on the ship
yes I'll shoot you
right it's gonna take a little bit I'll
let you guys all hang out here go I'll
get drunk and watch the ship do we have
beer here yeah there's a tanker
downstairs are you serious yeah bottom
floor or out okay I'm taking it you guys
you know they're wooden planks here by
the way yeah yep okay
I think the monstrous remains to the
northwest Beach keep a weather eye at
lies in wait for the light health high
or like wow so we had ways to rescue me
you gotta wait til the Sun rises the
rest no we can use your compass to go oh
wait look at it again fiction keep a
weather eye it lies in wait for a light
held high I'm assuming yes son or or or
or Atlantan I think there is a monstrous
wreck there's either shipwreck or bones
of a thing of them won't stop won't stop
alright guys I'm in no shape to drive
this so take your three hammers oh there
it is quite drunk alright so here's the
monster [ __ ] what is that well sure
dragon okay so there's a light here so
what is the riddle read again you get to
look what there's the shadow pointing to
it or something the riddle reads seek
the monsters remains the Northwest Beach
we gonna keep a weather eye it lies and
wait before it light held high so why
don't we hold up our lanterns
people whether I is like the shadow of
the eye that's what I'm thinking instead
of ephod maybe I'll go inside it I do
like a early see on my screen oh I got
downstairs somehow oh no what happened
I am Oh God Rob's area under attack I
also I lost guys I'm lost
Jesus I did Kenji I keep falling down so
not sure all right let's check the
riddle done seek the monstrous remains
we did that keep a weather eye guy
people would keep a weather so I think
Mike's right I think we need to wait
till noon no Rob said that yeah for a
light how high thank you
I think what are you to wait until noon
really yeah wait you said it's a long
long quest right or you just started
hanging around it
oh it's right there what is that
different one but that is different one
day it works a lot on it whoa that's
awesome good it's a captain's to chest
it's for you Nick that's for me no don't
give it to him
Oh watch out Jade you're completely
surrounded whoa and I smoked them all as
you see that's cool uh for how were you
notified the boat I don't know where I
am
Oh light yeah I'm I'm coming time busy
on your visit oh this isn't where the
the treasure is right there's one more
clue so I think like something needs to
happen anyway wait until you know
whether I wait for a light how high it
lies in wait I mean maybe you tried
digging inside of it but like no just
well just hold on drink like hold your
lantern I'm okay did you already try
seeing if the eye of the giant keeps
cast shadow okay I got it
yeah there you go so I had all the way
hold it up high nine three would that do
Odom's the southeast now yeah go across
what did you get back oh you have a
chest when we put it in the stash your
party broking husband
everywhere hey wait wait wait wait we
want to go south with me oh you vomited
sorry
gross dude we're going something cool
right yeah my god you who are spewing I
can't see it doesn't turn will you stop
throwing up on me
southeast so we really give her skull
toe
yeah ah I wish I could say that I'm
gonna grab some I think having this up
but this is how I control okay I got
upstairs nope so we're looking for skull
totems god Oh are these those are skill
totems check come back yeah we need some
help find skill totems
I gotta sober up hmm a lot of items oh
here good goal southwest something mean
step right now
southeast I think South pins okay
it's all nice make a minute or so I
think it's al guys and you got it back
all right let's go totems no these are
those are gold totems all right I found
them here they are all right so which
direction do I need to go Jake east by
southeast I think it said so it's but oh
god I'm coming there's a skeleton that's
alive here to keep a weather eye by
southeast misses no East by northeast
east by north and you're eight paces
from it okay but I don't even know where
you are
yeah don't look around oh then it three
no you got a dig five so is that our
chefs up yeah hey oh we're closed all
right let's see
and you're so drunk you forgot where you
parked defame hey how do you know I need
some backup I got you back by the ship
I'm heading back
[ __ ] oh if you smoke anything where I
can't see you from here
alright now we'll dig all right dig dig
dig
Gus who's having fun I'll having fun oh
I see you I see someone whoa whoa I want
to try to hit you with Jake I'm not sure
if that's Rob I'm not sure if our our
good friends
John Luke and Tay in the back and Al but
if you guys can hear us if they're
questioned why are you guys send them to
us all right I need you now Mike oh I
don't
I ran out shooting at you there you go
these guys are giving me a hard time
yeah Jay I just gauged launched itself
over I'm coming oh we got some combat
I'm coming put some clothes on got a
shaking me down oh okay we'll Nicki with
the chair captain's all right corporal
Rob it's just kind of smoky a banana
weirdly there's bananas in the ship damn
IRA I'm good I'm all better now oh
there's great skeletons chasing it
wherever you guys are putting the chest
down the bottom same spot yeah I didn't
the bottom deck owning cannonballs
get some cannibals all right we going
next Porter goes in we is the quest over
is there another one
no the quest is not over we have another
Island with this is no chess Sunday so
we can get another two chests all right
let's do it
let's rack them up baby all right cool
I'll Drive all right Mike's driving we
are looking for Casimir to show me what
I'm looking for mind India just the
sails on this one ship ship drunkard
Mike has become my nickname according to
the omec ship trunk pan all right and
people watching notice I sobered up
before I got all play it says Rob I
figure you have a quick chat yeah car
ends this look like that don't drink and
drive alright I hope I put my map it's
gonna be larmy right um where are we is
that look like it no no no that's not it
it is we're gonna justice sails it's
it's like an island house why does it
look like that one looks like two
nipples looks like two nipples yeah like
this yeah yeah that's it yeah that's it
and some in north east and south west
side to the island uh what turning
how many enemies I think it's just
infinitely so she no no I think you mean
Zach enemy types I've only seen the
shard on the skeleton strong skeletons
and then other players is okay have we
confirmed that PvP is present in the
beta no I mean I've seen anyone good
Nick and I saw another boat but that was
it they didn't even interact so we need
to the southwest yes so turn the
generator no so let's turn Isle of last
words let's turn the ship around
come on a second show yeah we got to
turn the ship around was it the south
west show me we're past the island last
words oh wait we don't wanna go to I
love LA we don't or its somebody anymore
it's a different one that's mark it was
one Nick found and I'll turn you back
out and then go down it's right there
you unmarked that other one
I gotta go straight south and also we
need to raise the anchor and move this
sails
okay can someone named that catch the
wind
bring the anchor up who's doing the
sails anybody I can do this who's hoping
their map guys look beside me hey guys
this is a ride you up it's me naked
all right back to work don't even see
that right now yeah you do you once
we're gonna spend a hard right oh shoot
okay someone direct me again
oh man the sound I think I got a sound
right just go directly yeah but there's
an island in our way I gotta go we'll go
around it and go south go you can I say
you kind of gotta go around it well dude
I can go between those giggling Peaks
don't all right let's get these sails to
catch some wind so we get some speed all
right I'm gonna get to the crow's nest
the Crowsnest is that uh that wooden
thing sticking out the front all right
yes scallywag we simran target pirate
this whole time all right we only have a
navigator now we're kind of just going
more pirate my instinct I got you
covered
you have other talents how we're doing
it yeah I know but I have a compass
Robin but is that an outpost there's so
many other islands doubts about the
skeletons left that's where the skeleton
those where the skeletons live and you
go to close they will fire cannons on
you I know we need a day yeah let's just
do a drive-by which is you're not to
look so what you're gonna need to load
the camp okay well hold on hold on
someone check the map quick to make sure
I am and Dean going toward the right
island cuz there are a few sound okay
first off you're gonna collide with this
they're firing I they're firing at us
Golan I know are laughs we're good we're
good are left
we're head we're head okay starboard
cannons get on them
wow we that whoa there's a lot of
skeletons are attacking Wow there are a
lot of cannons up there go repair the
ship I'm gonna start circle around fire
cannon faster Mario Jake okay I'm the
ship's mom pass that we ships fine let's
forget it for now we can go back we
where I bet you there's a lot out there
you know the man stairs get on the map
which island am I going toward I got I
got hard right
oh yeah yeah that's why I mean I needed
someone down there all right well
whatever we got a skull keep in the
meantime I'm gonna go ahead and load
these oh [ __ ] there's a big rock right
here woah we are dipping I gotta go
right now
[ __ ] oh my god hard right oh my god
go left oh gosh I'm drunk I'm dropping
the anchor oh my god good job Jake
yeah oh my god who's been doing that was
robbed who's been driving this ship I
was making sure we avoided some
cannonballs thank you can you get back
on the map and once we're done once we
raise the anchor will you put some
clothes on Robert all right let's get on
the map while I'm yeah you're down there
all right
all the cannons are loaded beautiful
so that just this kid settles back we
can have a little bad Ken someone direct
me once I start steering cuz that threw
me high tides okay yeah you are you got
to turn the enemy around stay on there
because yeah
all right mm-hmm how we doing look at
this map I'm gonna straighten out one
side no it's interesting the weather's
been kind of lousy since we started
playing I know we haven't hadn't really
seen the Sun oh [ __ ] John show me the
map straighten out a little bit I move a
little bit yeah and you pull up right
next to the animal I'm gonna get off in
that though I got a tunnel which is
going here I think I see it now oh
that's a big island so we're going it is
big island yeah
Canon's or to swim or what Kenz oh just
like a foot oh it's like a fortress
except it is a fortress
that's dope whoa crooked masts alright
let me know in a drop anchor all Riley
know you love okay yeah you've been good
I got straighten out like whoa this is
cool me so there should be two of them
there should be two treasures here if we
would stock up on bananas well mama any
bananas in I'm gonna drop me all right
here Jeff Maggert yeah coffee
I'm gonna aim us a secret adding your
mass or the the sales and we drop it
actually that we raise it sounds right
raise the sails sorry just cuz like
it'll like flip around otherwise or yeah
I don't really I mean I it'll stay
straight if I was to land and then there
will just like pull your swing the ship
hi oh it's lower we don't need to right
now there are yeah someone shoot me
banana
Gerrard thank you fire oh that was a
beautiful shot huh do me do me good
bananas we're talking about where are
they at I think you're like a second
stairway by Mac all right Wow trying to
get your bearings straight on this is
gonna be difficult alright so right now
let's get underneath the bridge here so
if we're directly underneath the bridge
then we know we should go to the top
there's definitely something up there
yeah I'm itchin to get up there let's do
it cool off the ship alright alright so
I think there's one over here like near
the stair like there's one over there
yes definitely want to pay our it's no
no that way now it's a little power off
any like the middle I'll go with you how
did you find it
gosh I really don't know maybe it's
crossing a master to the right and
backwards
yeah we get down here in this cave yeah
definitely backwards - okay what's like
it's weird cave thing what do you think
that isn't about this I think is the
most difficult part of the game where
like you trying to get your bearings
straight the riddles are difficult but
this is kind of like you don't really
know north south east or west and so
you're kind of like looking oh nice
first try - Rogers trip I wonder how big
the area is that it lets you actually
make contact alright so if you're that
one than the other one so this would be
on the other side it's a chat thanks
Eric tanky chat so if you guys have any
questions in the chat we can answer that
all right so I just think
the other one is over here right shake
yeah it's about you can say my own scope
I can see your scope
alright I should dip oh is that a rocket
rocket I guess you are I'm Mikey I'm
coming with a treasure where are you
man wait hold on get are you back I see
some skeletons near me oh my god sure
every way oh really
do you need help no I got it finally on
one
how you doing here Jake we're okay
okay god I'm bored man has a question
good so I ran what is your questions
and also hello everyone the chat Lana
I'm over just now taking a look oh boy
it's complete I think we have six all
right I never see that shot no I think
it's on your scope Oh
I'm voice rounded we should look up top
dopes I bet you there's just knife these
bones alright alright hey grab the chest
alright we got another chest family we
have six chests so we should probably
head back to it let's see let's see if
there's still more unlined unless
Franklin Cortez wants to know if it's
free for everyone so in order to get
into the private beta what you would
need to do is preorder sea of thieves
and you get access to the beta which
runs until the 29th
I think that's an unless you were part
of the technical alpha the only way to
get in is if you preorder at this point
where is the ship he goes oh there it is
what's let's cash in all these chests
there's a cave no we're gonna do now
right cuz of what we completed looking
cause our ship is it's all about
drinking grog cuz everybody we're gonna
do let's see if there's anything else on
this island are you gonna go up top yeah
we go up top there's got to be something
up here right I don't know there it's
also important to note that there are
different types of chests worth
different values and they have different
types of effects effects there are also
random chests so let's say you're just
on an island you start you just start
digging you could get lucky you find
something pretty sweet it's not an
efficient way to spend your time then no
not efficient but oh we're just stealing
something there's got to be something
it's six chests
I don't think there's any way she should
bring the chest back and maybe we'll buy
some cosmetic item hmm let's get you a
hat captain
I want a hat so bad all right we all
hear it I don't think there's anything
here no I'm not all right let's go
sweet Oh can't say anything so if if
Jake were to get separated from us right
now there would be a mermaid
oh that would be able to come and save
him Irmo years can leave me the mermaid
would come and get Jake but if Jake
finds a chest the mermaid will not
transfer the chest which is sad all he
wants to know when the release date is
March 20 correct Mike mm-hm
March 20th is the official release toner
so you know gonna bethe before then
probably at Sue's birthday my friend
Tony Wilson Chris 19 no one knows him oh
that was the joke I think you said we
Tony Wilson's for why didn't expecting
around on this long here we go we're off
we're we going we need to go to dagger
tooth outposts so that's gonna be 2 done
when are you guys leaving oh my god
we're trying yes sorry Jeff over here
just grab a ride on a merman drop anchor
no wait are we steering towards the Jake
I'm sorry where's the mermaid it'll see
the light will come up through the water
I'm swimming after you I don't know
where I'm going no no no look Nick go
down zoom out yeah awesome much more wow
we have a while to go all right we can
go to a different one or gonna stay
there go back you're not you're not hold
on just a sign we're gonna fun okay Nick
what's going out closer there no it's
gonna take as long I go around the isle
of where it made the ice to merge I seen
the rock I see there I've got I got
straighten out after the rottens Jake
and I'm Jake will spawn back and I broke
what's up
thanks for waiting for me no you don't
know if not we can go to this one when
you go to the galleons great Matt wasn't
your idea Mike sure that works is your
idea
I'll shoot you I don't care all right go
straight past goals boys skulls keep the
that's where the skeletons are tight you
guys want to go fight some skeletons or
you want to go cash em all right it's
ashes and then we'll do how can we
should cash in
we should cash because if they go by
anyway we should cash in get some
cosmetic items we can look really sick
and go straight by it let's do it cash
in I wish you would the Sun would come
up so I could see yeah it's very dark
this place session so far oh yeah so any
other questions there's a watch right
someone I suspect they can get on Steam
I believe not but it's annoying to PC
just coming to PC when they sort of
export Xbox play anywhere
four people can play together by
segments you and players Franklin
schools
it's cross play you can now they've
added two person vessel week I'm gonna
decide and can someone go we're in the
wind can someone move the sails we would
go pretty funny the sails I've got an
important job as a lookout I can't do it
so I'm like no problem I will leave the
same players can enjoy nor was I a
server sighs do you have an idea I'm not
sure I mean the max plays poorly but
but then there's two million other
people around no no I don't know my name
server sighs I have no clue so far we've
only Nick and I have only seen one other
ships so play guys going down the
starboard cannons in case these
skeletons try to come out it when you
play the advance of going around Oh
during the alpha
I've recommended that people with swords
Jean yeah be to hit them who saw I hit
the island Wow Lee though look at that
so how are we gonna do it yeah that
one's guys decide someone's gonna have
to stand the boat while we siege the
island Oh No
yeah I don't know I don't mind I used to
circle on it Oh am I going over the
island still at the right island can
someone I'll check
I can't just sail in my way doesn't mean
that's the point
all right you want to go and I'm gonna
well stay on there until I start now I
know that you'll tell anyone to start
straightening you should get rid of some
of those markers it's not no say that
add more tell me tell me you want to go
to the other the first marker that I
just made and then we'll go something
much harder to steer if I wasn't in the
same change if my focus I really thought
cuz it this yeah it's got to be this
right here it is it's absolutely that
alright I'm a scout for oh I got
straighten out now you didn't tell me
say you're entirely navigator you're
looking good
okay Nick's not allowed to do that man
delete the map look you know we should
do with Nick yeah I know what you're
doing Mike I know what you're doing my
strongest you think you're sly so
apparently you can put people if you
vote you can say you can cause I'm uni
and put and put someone enough
and you know and you can put someone in
this here dog the only vote needed for
Nick right now right there
why are you voting like because you're a
terrible navigator isn't messing with
our map and you're a terrible ship
driver nah Rob do you can look at this
ass of course we're going on can someone
get ready to near the anchor please come
in there keep an eye on further [ __ ]
right next to that dock it's me such a
ball those sick your sidled down the
ladder uh drop anchor
no one's over there drop anchor a drop
drop it yeah I could be lost sick that's
perfect seems like we're the only ship
here that was really good we're uh
almost pulled up right alongside the
dock
alright let's get these chests alright
so there are specific types of Chet's
and you go to what designated cellars
are no we can all give them both right
now we can just bring them all to our
the facts and we're doing the gold
Porter's okay it's kind of weird you
know like why are we bringing these
chests and these people you know why
don't we just take the gold or so yeah
we're pirates is it because it's more
about like reputation I'm actually alone
yeah nothing cosmetic is a good question
why wouldn't we just pay for the
cosmetic items with the gold in these
chants why not cut out the middleman I
also these big like these big like birds
like the bird skeletons wonder I wonder
if they're real alright yes no yes so
there's bringing this - this guy - yeah
yeah find this bird in the wild whoa
that Gollum is worth four hundred twenty
four gold King Wow hundred twelve gold
that's awesome is there all the chests
no that was 112 they'll probably one
more by the time I ask 49:10 for the
gold quarters hi I'm gonna go shop so
keep it coming
let's go to the shop maybe there's still
one more shell and no one's hearing I'm
on an open no this is not that's it so
this is a different faction and this is
like the witchdoctor faction
my favorite faction I'm at the bar if
you guys need me that's the ball huh all
right so the cosmetic shop what they're
wearing it was all right well sure every
island is different remember was like
closer to the beat let me up here I see
a ship logo this might be the other
faction nope this is it
and I really want to see another ship
shopkeeper oh wow look at this you guys
yeah it's different so it's items for
your ship so it changes the way certain
things look so you can get a cool
Admiral shut off one beer grog whatever
it is is I sit right here oh I found
that a cosmetic do you think you can
find the blunderbuss it's the shotgun oh
look at that hat dick oh I'm looking I
just spent my money on that whoops
what'd you buy a hat I'll get some
clothes I did get that he's not this
captain yeah well I'm the one with a hat
on so whoo I like this coat I'm gonna
get this coat the Admiral jacket where
where's this up there did you just buy
the captain's that line no there's
another cap and say you got with a black
cool ass black beard one to buy my
good-looking regal one yours is the
tattered how do you think which one did
you buy the Admiral one with a red red
ribbon get the one underneath it the
black beard hat he took the captain's
hat no it's not the cabin so you just
move on the captain's hat is any hat the
captain where's the captain's hat
chooses the guys he took he took that
you know you're a boat away from getting
thrown it's actually an Admiral's hat
and all the littles hat I'm going with
this
maybe I'll get higher than Captain
actually should I get some should I get
this cool belt
I'll get the Adam I got that all right
someone in the chat had a question
regarding how do you recruit people to
do missions so we're and we're in a
party and we obviously all know each
other so that works out all right
cool do you know of any kind of like
voice like a single player yes makes
like match makes like so normally I've
just been inviting you guys but you can
load in and pick how many crew how many
people you want in a dull load how do
you go through your items you want to
change your outfit mm-hmm
go go back to the ship it's behind this
there's equipment Chester are not the
equipment shots the one next to it
splish-splash you were taking your bad
um alright what's next
God why kill another player so let's go
let's go fight those the skeletons uh
yeah should we get another requester
while we're here
yes we should go get a quick call Nick I
mean it's all right Jake
where'd you say the outfit thing was um
behind the stairs way back there
Wow look you can go there that's
equipment oh did you go did you go up
there Nick to the boat up top and here
we go today what you go to the boat up
top
no I did not I'm gonna go there do not
put this dump on here guy there's always
like something in the horizon that looks
kind of like a ship that's deceiving you
know like this thing all right how do I
look
sure do the ill-gotten loot of marooning
mo absolutely we did that Alma knows
where are you
we didn't matter all the early let's do
Moroni more items on my order can
upgrade and get a new one
are you sure yeah what's up good
alright alright hey look at me someone
look at me I don't want to go into the
storm to the food I like the forbidden
gold of bold Tom Thunder you look great
the hidden gold the but I think hidden
gold Roger
Jolly Roger Roger sorry Oh project
what's the job project this sounds like
Steve Jobs Roger it was waiting for you
imagine I'm captain full on your [ __ ]
first [ __ ] free ship on the stream the
borders saying whose plane that's have
you seen this I'm the cooks assistant
all right I'm gonna get some Amy that's
just someone look at me someone look at
me I already know I don't you ready to
dress wait am I wearing it fashion show
on ship yeah where's the camel I don't
know I'm very gun it's I know if I the
second stairway like right when you go
up the stairs if you're coming from the
bottom deck I wonder what this is all
about I think I'll find a treasure chest
appear neck you are you growing up there
oh yeah so I say we go and we get in the
back we go fight that skeleton island
take it on all right now look at Jake
anchors coming up alright let's jump no
not there and the ship I can't find the
ammo oh there it is give me that ammo
there's a sniper
all right I'm good don't push it
hold on wait for me this done trying Tom
Mix teen exponent opposite its bully
we're just we're equally as strong so no
Mars all right so no Mars
it is only first person as far as I know
yes look at my jacket my jacket oh no
you were in the same jacket wait Rob
okay you know you could do right now if
you voted cute can we not we're not
gonna cause immunity right now I want it
let's get into some action below wrist
oh yeah I don't trust this captain
leading us into battle and you want you
want him outside of that cage let's load
all the cannons good call
yes and we also need to turn around all
the way around fine that one's loaded
I'm still gonna need a navigator okay
sounds loaded we need to turn all the
way around it gonna smoky yes gonna take
a wide berth toward the edge of the
world Skokie the sails could use some
adjusting once we turn around the wind's
coming up
wait wait wait wait wait stay on the map
even if you can see the wick of the
space steers like a boat also make sure
to stock up on bananas too when we go
another great tip let's do that
guys what Kali also if we crashed again
we didn't we didn't counter and faster
crash was great
this is tickle yeah yeah the cooks
assistant keep turning text you guys
find the worth of banana we're gonna
keep bananas there in the barrel right
there right right there a barrel next to
the grog one run wrong no this is it's
empty
oh sorry right to the right of it no no
that's that has bananas it so it's empty
we did two fights more I wish every stop
okay stop stop stop
I know I am I am I am happy Nana's way
told me to drop anchor
no we're nowhere in area I just have a
straight arrow stop all right now go
straight I'm gonna let this ship steer
itself meanwhile don't you dare get
hammered I'm not kidding
she's gonna have a beer or seven couple
seven beers ranking left it but the beer
still in my cup from the island oh I
think I see it you see it up there yeah
cheap beer turns me down before fighting
what is that over there Nick I'd be
that's right there it's just directly
off also Nick I just know it's during
the bonus say something it doesn't want
to be steered right now or going
straight Nick you're the captain I'm
steering if you do slip once okay you're
out you're in the brig Rob's the last
we'll be going into the jail cell I'm
not I just want to make second please
all right well if useful as in if you
fall off that mask look at the wheel
when you're just I'm not touching it
you're drunk
great I'm not touching it I don't know
where it is wait where is that it's
still a Bristol
yeah don't trust my aim aim like you're
useless slightly super sir we're gonna
have to behave a Pui pirating under the
influence are we going away it's
actually there is such thing as a DUI a
bike on the influence right I thought
was voting on doing it in place you know
that's it that's a thing we have I said
pee pee
Nick that's real close really that far
but that's life that's blood it's puking
all over this great and that just can
pilot can it's right in front of us yeah
the why we gon still suck someone with
the sale oh yeah we gonna catch that
catch that was just fella yeah in live
in that wind life very not fun joke for
anybody outside of his office all right
so we're gonna oh yeah oh that's oh I'm
sobering up at exactly the right time
I'm gonna take a heart okay here's what
we're gonna do can you guys wait lift
two of the sails so I can actually
circle the island without flying by it
should I lift today's the back - yeah
he's the back - you want to get a little
closer I know but I'm raising this won't
hurt me still more raising really keep
the front one going went yeah I'll ship
this dope I can steer like a [ __ ]
pullin out all right what's like these
brochures shot it was a warning shot you
know roughly the feathers a bit there we
go this is sick I could steer like a
madman now I'm sober as well so we're
you know don't attack them oh you want
to get it you get a cannon urge you
something yes somebody fired me out of
the can we're side cannons we're gonna
shoot him in inside their fortress all
right get your ass did you mess this up
all right you're in jail all right all
right German frost sky Oh your turn I'm
sorry ah we got a cannon tower coming up
on our port side if you can hit that
like anything you want to know I know
oh there you want about our know what
guys I'm in the tower I'm in the tower
all right you're going to Nick I'm
climbing the tower
good luck my friend
what are you made of rubber Jesus I
didn't hit it
Oh a mantra my view literally like
straight up missed and kept going
they're not bouncing here really we
scared I will steal their [ __ ] now I've
heard I'll keep circling it's a little I
can always act like a horny Chardon oh
my god I got a pretty good question
oh you did oh yeah yeah I think this is
pretty empty oh my God we're gonna be
all right
oh we can get back into camp we say
we're gonna launch back on the boat you
can't oh I know I can then we're gonna
see if I have the skill popular you see
any treasure huh nice and shredded might
keep keep coming around okay keep coming
around
yeah I got good look what he used to
[ __ ] excuse my French their mics no
I'll come back for you do all my look at
this leave me hey [ __ ] you know we
can spawn back on this [ __ ] hey wait
guys let me fill up on beer first oh
[ __ ] that's such [ __ ] let's get back
on the ship first and then you're going
to jail congratulation on Balan I'll see
you guys later
how do we spawn back on the ship we have
the final I see it burn man there's a
cannon over here maybe I can launch
myself to it why do you think about that
but these next ones and he's too far
it's now to be I'm not even on a ship
Maura you guys spooked me oh my god
you're so go to jail walk up on bananas
my friend you're gonna be in there a
long time I don't even know where the
ship is anymore
I'm going to we're made wait where's
sheena hi well I see one I need you I
need your assistance
we should start that quest too after we
lock my god you guys won't regret this
alright alright alright time to lock
them up and lock him up how do I do it
let's see here oh we're headed Ritzer as
a rock oh [ __ ] not such an easy gig
steering the ship huh oh cool that's
cool yeah let's go alright how do I do
it
none go to a pancake face another Jax
today give me beer quick Knesset log in
the break where's your bad boy bad bad
boy [ __ ]
hold on I'm gonna go fill my pail with
water and splash him with it oh that's
an amazing idea
oh we're out of beer cuz my drunk at all
oh how do we refuel all this stuff we
have these as barely find I want to go
see here's my here's my problem this is
yeah I got a promise is born oh there's
water on the ship water on the ship I'm
not joking we're following it get it
around right what does he poke the hole
is yeah
controlled flooding if you will all
right Mikey watching yeah I don't know
what else I would do out of this bowl
right here is this good or we can just
keep we can move we can just put dump
water in here how do we drive into an
island don't you that's a pretty good
idea listen how are you getting water
you're going on off the ship yeah come
on it looks like water is actually
filling then okay let's just say it
won't fill over time well can I just
shoot can I just shoot this you try
shooting holes bounding over yeah or
just Mike are you paying attention this
is very hard on a trail Mike you don't
to do the nice quest
Westerman boring let's well I'm bored
right now watching this okay you need to
steer into an island if you want to try
to drown me okay if you say so
this isn't working hey tight hang tight
Michael's chicks got her idea Kevin des
alright we're coming right at a rock no
Jake Jake I will give you all the
bananas I have to give me out of needs
and bars you know holding bananas yes
I've got five of them I'll give you all
nothing - I'll give more you can how are
you dude water riches beyond your
wildest water down here so I can keep
scooping it up Jake more wealth and you
can imagine it no you guys are gonna
drown - no we're not all think [ __ ] well
how does John what would John
are you doing are you crashing this
crashing this boat oh alright
please there's a line you cross between
humor and just plain cruelty okay here
you let the cross it here's your problem
right you got a whole your boat that's
your problem is it just one uh guys
there's water
hey don't burn it up quite a lot of
water I helped my knees you're damn
right a nice man that's funny
hey can I ask you a favor Jake quick
don't look you come here can you press
can you guys even to open the door for
my Jack Sparrow okay I put myself out of
here I'll get out through the water Jake
you let me know it's a good a good level
here hey excuse me this is probably a
bad time to tell you I can't swim now
Rob now now what let's seal it oh yeah
get to the top it's not even letting me
swim in here
oh you can still jumping in air oh thank
you good call
damn it sweat sick I found a loophole
Jane what do you mean that's all right
I'll just take the whole thing I'm gonna
sink the whole Jake damn thing listen
listening to this guy right have a
lockpick or anything oh
come join me cuz you want to sink it
take the boat remember earlier of times
year old flood do it do it do it do it
do it once Lynn do it you had one of
these Mike wouldn't vote him in - I did
it's been voting over like I did a
gaming of the magnet where is he I'm the
captain we got accountants down okay
this boat is barely Jake no Jake let's
vote Robin oh yeah how's that looking
Nick no no Robin yeah Rob people right
here yeah it's not so fun drowning in
this cage no we're Joey I locked it up
since there should enjoy when you walk
it but I say we sealed it alright this
is the hardship now what way do you have
like a deck of cards or something you
guys should be drowning yeah we're not
do another one
yeah no let's all go in here why would
we all go in here
why would you whiten one of us go in
here can you free Elysee boy I'm driving
all I am Charlie finally what the bowl
oh oh uh oh I found an escape oh it's oh
yes pretty good Nick
yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna find some way
to mess you up do any more water
okay can we move on and get you out yeah
I can I think you have to be there a
little while what
give me out yeah oh yeah oh yeah I voted
you out but vote released from brig can
vote to release us no keep Nick in here
is something you do to my town the Union
Nick right now to release us this is
boring I can't
ah you need my vote to release I knew
that they weren't gonna understand how
it operates or works I think we're
playing it sinking safety guys let's
[ __ ] him
and all three wasn't gonna bail from
this shot
let's get you out ha we're helping you
right now all right there's a rock up
there I want you alive baby all right
mutiny successful now we just do the
quest right Charlie taste changes the
screen no we're gonna jail cell
what do you do when that song connects
all right look at me lock up in the
bridge let me know all right we can or
at least Nick now you smell dude I voted
to release Nick okay
[Music]
ya know I voted to release some we need
another person to do it though
alright vote me out I'll blow you out
I'm gonna throw in another quest this is
a good one quest time the big one right
yeah more than a day long more than a
day you vote me out please
yeah I need to send a minute to my life
you're a pirate you don't have a wife
you're damn right all right I'll just
automatically vote you in since you're
in the groove had a good idea he'll Nick
drowning repeat that sounds like a well
lived I repeat all right please come out
here I've worn you out what do you have
- well no you guys did it yes I did no
you guys did on yourself out maybe
that's just like weird maybe that's like
your dad no I definitely did it oh no my
[ __ ] no maybe it's your new role you let
me out please no you're the prisoner
that's what happened someone needs to
take care of the cell okay I seem to
recall you at the forefront of the
campaign against me as a man yeah
because you drove the ship away from us
yeah but that was all in can you let me
out please
all right your filthy hands are empty of
coin go to shipwreck Bay I want to steer
the ship can you let me as this south
wing I voted him out no he didn't vote
him out I I did he's not I'm looking at
your screen I was lying he just changed
the wrong thing vote him out dip bread
this is funny I feel powerful right now
a shipwreck Bay is pretty close to us
vote now okay well what about when we
get to the island I don't trust my
oh oh it's not fun is it when you're the
one in the brig isn't it
Oh Nikki captain Deb's is not liking
being in jail huh what did he what's the
word Karma
this is a live stream we need to be
productive yeah but how are we getting
there let's get to the island first
before I agree to anything vote him out
well go app and show me how I get there
I met the man you have to turn vote him
out yeah what a real quest you want to
go west
what about this stream is so fun hi guys
so where are we going go to the map and
get me the best I'm at the web okay I'm
turning around
hey does anyone have control of the
twitch chat can we ban a certain coupe
shoe right through the gap please Thanks
can I come out please vote him out we're
getting I don't trust you guys yet we're
getting to the island first I think
you're overestimating how fun this dream
was to watch before you were in jail
can you overrated thing I'm not voting
them right back you could just do that
now and then you guys yeah put him in
jail I'm putting the next still gonna be
in there that lets me be born what's
happening you got voted out man oh yeah
yeah oh yeah all right soonish back
straight now Mike back the values at
hand guys Jay is the only one working
eyes inductive they're just there's a
shipwreck oh let's do it all right we're
straightened out shipwreck I'll get
ready on the anchor tongue I'm gonna
drop it tell me someone tell me I was
far away okay [ __ ] this game gets heated
dude we gotta turn some of these sails
she's turning it on top of a sour cream
and he'll be fine
who said that
we keep some please ban him who's a
moderate yeah the more you get annoyed
by it the more we're good
guys okay or do we drop anchor
should we no no no we're nowhere near a
known to drop anchor can someone get on
the map roll we're gonna get this first
we're doing this um
chipper the shipwreck first a little to
the right oh there's a seagull it's okay
oh my god Oh sloth oh I see yeah pretty
far away but okay no no we're good
all right there oh you between school
early Oh perfect
I lost the chip oh god don't shoot
terrible hit food hi dude dude okay
let's go I'll watch this [ __ ] for real
tell me what you guys find out there oh
it's the wreck of the feared dragon
again Nick oh there wasn't anything
there last time the last time it was
like partly in the water was there is it
it's pretty it's down pretty low is it
is it completely submerged yeah it's
okay wait so when you go to the screen
says all other crews what is that oh
wait that's just muting no that's so is
there any voice chat probably a yes yeah
how else would you meet other crews yeah
why else what you need to that makes
sense yeah yeah sure
where our neck which direction are they
I have no idea I don't see the slow
there they are
we're dead straight ahead of us yeah see
the seagull what do you know I'm really
drunk oh yeah
you just damn banana no banana once I'll
help you rob I see the Sharks chasing
you
I control or you find anything sanely
good whoa
I'm hoping yeah no I didn't find
anything and I'm dead no oh I can go so
Rob is gonna go to the ship of the
Damned I love this place
oh boy oh boy if you search her over
there you can eat a banana and you'll be
okay oh no I'm out of hook huh nobody
potassium yeah I got to obey Fanta I
could live here forever
whoa Saturday I'm fine treasure not yet
now who's this dude dad
that's me no this guy right here oh oh
the Sailor of the Damned did we all die
it's Davy Jones there he is
oh your ghost body Mike what are you
doing is he sailing away oh oh oh
Mike oh all right going back to the real
world killed you guys sharks and you're
gonna mermaid sharks sweet while you're
back that's what I plan are you headed
in the right direction then you just go
direction are we is still doing this
quest yes yes I think I'll check them
out actually anyone check them out we're
going to shipwreck way we're going oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] retreat is right ahead of us
we need to go there know when you go to
shipwreck Bay what about the other ones
coz we construe maps wait Han make sure
you bring a map that's close we have two
maps and she won with a is close I gotta
go around the crooked masts and then
don't me to raise the sail Oh No
Kat busy wants to know what the banana
is for that's your healing item yeah
that's right loose I raised a little bit
it's delicious
don't drop it when we say gun Matt we're
just on raising the sail we turn and
then I'll drop it once we got it um
the back sale well i Nicktoons like five
more seconds let's just say are you want
five more seconds
hmm man I really wanted well the crooked
master
oh that we've been there already boy
I'll look back at the map again nah
oh really my white Rob next trip Mike
straight now we haven't seen another
ship oh yes straight now I am I gotta go
right a little bit too anyway I like it
there's not like an a marker on my UI
yeah I guess that's part of the game can
I get ya we've been there already
Toys R Us closed what oh that same guy
keep saying it nevermind
now Toys R Us is not closed they're
closing a few locations I just went to
one over Christmas shipwreck Bay we're
almost there and you hit with bananas
well nah nah just eat it
Richard deliver for funny here we
answered down by my mom's and what what
do you be able to heal with it you put
it in your face
stem first am I going right now in him I
don't know let's find out play some
music
liven yeah liven it up you get one I'm
looking at her backwards so yeah you
know turn a little bit but yeah you're
pretty good
[Music]
shipwreck Bay that's promising
oh there's a rock in front us holy [ __ ]
we don't get rocks don't show up in the
map you're chillin Oh are we now just
kidding yeah play some music let's all
do it play music with me Rob you got it
dude no I'm just gonna show you now so
if that's a clock can you show it to me
oh my god I'm late
fish oh my god I'm late why does it say
11 isn't the 11th of whatever month its
11th dude dude I was supposed to be home
two hours ago my mom's gonna kill my
months late
you look like it you really do look like
a dishonored character yeah guys this is
this right here you know what what's
ironic about it being called shipwreck
Bay then I'm gonna steer us straight
into it
I'm not just kidding um although that
does make me worry that there's stuff
under the water that we're gonna run too
there are definitely some shot can
someone get out the anchor and get ready
oh yeah I could call my good call what
something eyes me Nick what's this
what's what oh [ __ ] brac drop the anchor
drop Jager those are no visitors items
there's no ship right there oh there's
doves and barrels you guys can take a
ship I'm gonna go check out that
shipwreck you check out the shipwreck
and we'll go to the island
I'm headed Lee island so there's items
in those barrels yeah middle island -
taking the slow way fellas
whoa you're crazy man
what's in these Oh what about bananas
and eat barrels it's perfect wooden
plank I got some bananas - you take the
bananas and you bring them back to the
ship you can reload the other crates hi
bananas what is this cannonballs we mean
reload though that would again you can
refill your ship with like animals with
ammo so you can totally check closer you
the currency of banana equates to you
can store that in your ship so some of
the needs and they can go get them in
the ship call a buoy if you can bring
you closer that'd be good but close it
means closer to us not like away don't
like fish your mind washed up doggies
swing in the gym find the what why don't
I like trying to watch the movie on the
South Shores no turning back when it
should actually need for come with
bananas okay that's about Stewart
grab it you found it
yep yep go are you gonna do a gang
attacked person yeah alright I am
staring for you guys share with me Rob
and I will come in with a cannons
blazing oh hell yeah
wait can you raise me we got a reasoning
beneath the monsterous remains looking
out to the North Sea's Year award is
almost found
alright so we're gonna find that remains
to the north
let's park this oh yeah wait help me
raise the anchor it's taking so long
oh there it is ACM Jake Rosetta it's
gotta be it monstrous remains that's a
ship actually I like this still think
it's a good cage here we go that are
already steering left whoops this might
be it over here to the dresser salesman
know where you're sitting into a win huh
yeah stress remains we'll come pick you
guys up
there's and get some cannon fire in
there that's a weird-looking cloud it's
kind of silver lining up all right eight
paces East by northeast this FS eight
paces north white north east but North
East so that what side the are you guys
on yeah North is in that direction
yeah I've coming around that side East
by northeast so it's gonna what cannons
robbed it's like further this way isn't
it what sport again it's this way is
that it wasn't no I'm a big dead clients
hours right okay I was dressed as Bowser
front I'm sorry I don't know [ __ ] lingo
I wrote oh hell what is it
pelipper is there a leveling system
there's a leveling system in that I see
I see you guys have each faction we're
uh we're here I don't know I see you
really these guys what's your right oh
all right there it is we'll come around
the other side
there's a little bit system in the fact
that you can drop anchor this I can come
gain more you level up factions like
destined a disease yeah I see one of
them right there I don't even know
they're only dropping right no no you
guys can catch everything here I'm
coming toward you I got a pullout fast
though huh oh my god but in a second
move it
okay right now by that skeleton yeah I
can't move off his sandwich my friend we
were in Titanic when there's the heavy
iceberg oh they're at the cruise like
gentlemen it's it's been an honor
but an honor playing with you one last
song do you know I haven't hit him it
seems like you damn well this might be a
good place to end right this one one
ninety minutes yeah it's been it's 3:30
uh we're all south but she just Mike's
not having fun hi guys no we didn't
finish this ice ooh I know
we're gonna go get treasure and bring it
back to the island that sounds be doing
waling like this game I'm making it fun
by mess with any news all right yeah
it's kind of boring me I think I can see
why it's fun but I could see it also
wearing off after about 90 minutes
yeah you just needs is like a giant
squid yeah you know what I mean a nice
boss fight I'm having I'm having fun
like doing stuff the game is not telling
me to but allowing for we haven't really
done many of the really difficult ones
yet I drank and I did a couple really
difficult quests
but it's my job to be critical and I'm
gonna say I'm not having a ton of fun I
think a wore off after sixty minutes
okay
I totally disagree that's fine no but I
cannot have fun with the game once it
looks like what we find a replacement
for yeah the crew okay you just ran with
you just I'm trying to get out of here
what are you doing anyway
I'm down here panting the boat working
my butt off
yeah Jake is the all-star here this is
fun though
we're going straight I don't know
nothing's really happening a ton more
we're sharing the boat all right it's
this next time we need to get to let me
let me steer you guys do that yeah you
can steer I'm gonna find something fun
to do kryten's fall this is it nope now
this is fun right here yeah I don't know
if a here's John Luke or think it's are
we uh let's um which how should we end
it
yeah what's uh well I thought the boat
crash would be a good way
let's get full speed and just Rama okay
some rock why we already did that like
three times
no okay at top speed find us something
fun to do and then we'll do that at the
end of stream what should we do okay I
guess we're I guess we're done no this
has been an interesting conclusion
say the least well let's find something
to do what what else have we not shown
the audience well it depends it depends
on what you get and so there's x marks
the spot
there are what we done those idols there
are specific chests like Jake and I
found a couple of the drunk chests
earlier then one run drunk when you
carry them it's alright why camera it's
all about luck
it's all about luck Jake we wanna sign
us off yeah
alright thank you for joining our vessel
for this hour and a half voyage through
the sea of thieves my thanks to Jake and
Rob it's not Mike because he locked me
in the brig for to know that happened
yeah thank you guys for hanging out with
us and being look out for some more sea
of thieves content I don't know what's
gonna happen when the game launches I
made xx Mabel with you some comics Julia
will do some cutaways it man March sorry
marks 20 will do a little let's play
series we'll see we'll see
but thanks for hanging out with us we'll
see you next time
[Music]